Psychologists use the general rule of 7 plus or minus 2 when referring to our
ability to chunk information into units. Meaning 7 digits or 9 digits, that
would be plus 2, or 5 digits, minus 2. So chunking is one way to remember
things. But how do we get our short term memory to allow us to remember things
such as phone numbers or directions to the mall? Or even the vocabulary words
from this lesson? One theory by psychologist Alan Baddeley suggests that there
are three processes involved in working memory. The first is attending to the
stimulus. That is, we're aware, or mindful of it. The second part of the
process is storing information about the stimulus. And the third part is
actually rehearsing what is stored. Let's go to Susan for a little more detail
about this.